here is kimberly crenshaw defending
critical race theory which is what the
democratic party is pushing
critical race theory is basically just a
name for let's tear down all of the
systems
and restore systems of actual
discrimination reverse discrimination
in order to restore some sort of
equality of outcome
critical race theory just says let's pay
attention to
what has happened in this country and
how what has happened in this country
is continuing to create differential
outcomes
so we can become that country that we
say we are
so critically theory is not
anti-patriotic in fact
it is more patriotic than those who are
opposed to it because we believe in the
13th and the 14th and the 15th amendment
we believe in the promises of equality
and we know we can't get there if we
can't
confront and talk honestly about
inequality
okay that's just untrue okay so when she
says that proponents of critical race
theory believe in the 13th 14th and 15th
amendment derek bell
explicitly says that he doesn't believe
in processes like due process he doesn't
believe
in things like equal justice before law
right those are those are
merely fig leaves for systems of white
supremacy and racism what she's talking
about is not actual critical race theory
what she is talking about is is
something broader and simpler and
and and really not associated with crt
right she's saying something that is
true which is that history has an impact
on the present
but one thing that you'll notice from
critical race theory is they they
actually don't want to attempt to even
quantify
what impact history has on the present
because quantification
could lead to the conclusion that the
vast majority of disparity today is not
the result of historic discrimination
the vast majority of disparity today is
the result of individual decision making
that is not equally distributed by
communities right that is what critical
race theory does not want to argue
okay well so these folks are making that
argument that deeply undermines
a basic and fundamental american
principles
and then they're surprised when there's
blowback and they suggest that any
blowback is evidence of your racism
again it's it's trying to create these
sort of
unfalsifiable theses so the thesis from
the left on january 6th that's
unfalsifiable is the right is
responsible
for january 6 broadly speaking and if
you say no we're not then that's just
evidence that you don't take january 6
seriously and they're doing the same
thing with regard to american racism
they say that if you oppose crt it's
because you're a racist and if you
accept crt
it's because you're accepting your own
racism
and and not only that if you oppose it
if you oppose crt and you point out the
shortcomings of people like nicole
hannah jones who's a variator and a liar
if you point out that she should not
have a tenured position at a major
american university because she is not
qualified to do so
because she has fabricated history
because she ignored criticism
because she has doxed people because
she's a terrible candidate to be a
professor at a major university
then this means that you're a racist the
university of north carolina has now
rescinded a ten-year offer to
1619 project author nicole hannah jones
she should never have been offered this
in the first place according to a report
by nc policy watch
unc is backing down from offering hannah
jones a tenured position at its
journalism school because she's not a
journalist
well instead they will offer her a fixed
five-year contract according to a report
by nc
policy watch the change in plans comes
three weeks after was announced that she
would have a tenured position at the
university which is kind of incredible
that she was just offered tenure right
off the bat usually you have to earn
your way into tenure at a major american
university particularly if you have no
academic background
the way nicole hannah jones has no
academic background she's not a
professor she's not a phd she hasn't
taught at a major american university
very weird to be offered a 10-year track
position right off the bat
that's very strange okay it's
disappointing said susan king dean of
unc hussman school of journalism and
media
it's not what we wanted i'm afraid it
will have a chilling effect okay so
first of all
unc yeah if they wanted to hire her and
they knew this going in
they should give her frankly i think unc
should give her the 10-year track
position because i think that people
should recognize unc for what it is
but should they ever have offered it to
her no they should never have offered it
to her because she absolutely does not
deserve it
she's 100 not a person who deserves a
10-year track position
or a 10-year position right off the bat
at a major american university the fact
that she was granted it is just evidence
of how deeply crt has seeped
into the american system of thought so
there are a lot of people on the left
were saying that's cancelled culture
if nicole hannah jones is not given a
10-year position at university of
north carolina okay well here's the deal
should again should she be canceled
should she lose that position she never
should have been offered it and it's a
taxpayer-funded institution university
of north carolina
taxpayer-funded institutions are not the
same as private universities if she'd
been hired at a private university i
would say she should keep her job
if she's a public university that's your
taxpayer dollars taxpayer dollars are a
very different thing
alrighty meanwhile crypto currencies you
may have noticed took a serious dive
over the course of the last
couple of days according to the uk daily
mail bitcoin has rallied after plunging
below the 40 000
mark for the first time in more than
three months as tesla boss elon musk
insists the company will not sell any of
its holdings in the cryptocurrency
despite the turbulence celebrities and
others who bought in early are still up
big but small investors who jumped on
the bitcoin trend in the past few months
may have suffered some ruinous losses
this is one of the problems with bitcoin
right now is that because the amount in
circulation in terms of being used by
that many people
is still not that high it can be
disproportionately affected by
swings from celebrities who decide that
they're not going to engage in more
bitcoin use for example investors had
rushed out of cryptocurrency earlier
wednesday after china sparked to market
panic when officials announced a
regulatory crackdown and this just
demonstrates by the way
how important bitcoin is going to be for
the future of
economic freedom because more and more
governments are going to start cracking
down on bitcoin in the same way
that during the 1930s government started
cracking down on the private ownership
of gold
because if you can trade in currencies
that are not government currencies
this allows you to divest from the
government's inflationary policies
and this is the thing that the
government cannot allow this has always
been my great fear
for bitcoin which effectually is just a
form of
precious metals that has been that has
been digitized
that's really all that bitcoin is the
volatility in bitcoin right now
is ineffective nobody knowing whether or
not governments are going to even allow
the circulation
of bitcoin but long-term i'm not sure
that governments can prevent it
which is why i've been a bitcoin fan for
quite a while
the the bitcoin had hit like 30 percent
drop before it retraced most of its
losses
after elon musk's vote of confidence by
late afternoon trade in new york the
currency was still down about 10
on the day but well off its earlier lows
musk indicated
that his company would not sell any of
its bitcoin holdings he tweeted on
wednesday morning tesla
has diamond hands diamond hands is slang
popularized by wall street bets which is
a reddit form indicating a refusal to
sell even in the face
of falling prices tesla stock was down
about 2.6
in afternoon trading good for musk for
pushing bitcoin frankly
he said i know one person wrote on
reddit i know today looks terrible and
lots of people lost too much money they
can they can't afford to lose but
markets always bounce back so let's not
do rash decisions
life is more important that of course is
is true
long term bitcoin is going to be
something that i believe
remains worthwhile particularly as
governments try to stop it in fact again
the value in bitcoin lies in the fact
that governments are going to try to
stop it
in the first place who's got two thumbs
and wants you to like and subscribe